Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill birds.
The Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
May 14th, 2012, um,
re I am sole role re I got
the house all to myself.
Nia is out of town, comes back tomorrow
and uh, my dogs out getting a tune up.
So I'm sitting in my house all by myself,
all by my lonesome.
I'd like to sit here and tell you that
the reason why I'm sitting here by myself
cause I told the bitches in my
life to get the fuck out. Right?
Like some pimp shit. And now I'm just
sitting here in some giant leather chair,
the head of an animal above me in my
study with a bunch of books around me that
I never read some creepy
toy from my childhood. Um,
no,
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
There's nobody here and I'm slowly
losing my mind. I'm eating like shit.
Um, had waffles like three
days in a row, you know,
cause I don't know how to make them
just for one. I don't have the recipe.
Usually make them for two people. And then
there's a couple of extra. So you know,
I just made the fucking batch because
the recipe I have says one egg,
so you know, if I cut it in half when we
put half a fucking egg in there, okay.
I don't know how to do that.
So I'm making all the waffles
and I'm using all this and uh,
I'm fucking, I'm out of whack.
I'm full of sugar and doe.
I went to the grocery store,
I'm like a single man.
I went to grocery store and they, you
know, rather than buy something to cook,
I go and I buy like, you know, parts
of a chicken that we're already cooked.
God knows when,
you know,
somebody hit it with a truck and then
they throw it on a fucking grill.
So for the first time in my life,
second time actually I actually had,
for lunch I had chicken and Waffles,
a staple in the African American community
and I have never understood that dish.
I love waffles. I love
chicken, but not together.
To me that was toothpaste
and orange juice. Both great
ideas. Just not together.
Right. And I had it and I got to
tell you, I still don't get it.
I don't get it. It's, it's like a,
it's like the sun and the moon at the same
time. It's just, it just freaks me out,
you know, is it breakfast or are or
have we gotten on with their day?
Should I be in my fucking
pajamas or should I be telling
you about my dad? Just,
you know, I dunno. I'm
losing my fucking mind.
I'm losing my mind. And then
tomorrow I leave, I leave to go do,
I'm doing an episode of um, Oh,
what the fuck is this show called?
That's embarrassing.
I don't even know what the show's called.
What's that one with that?
Did the check from a party of five
is on and she gives the hand jobs,
but she's, she's a good
person. What's it called?
Uh,
the fucking the,
yeah,
the hand job whisperer.
What the fuck's her name?
I'm doing that show during that show this
week I'm on the hand job whisperer and
I play one of the clients and uh,
she's going to rub one out. So, you know,
it was a long talk I had to have with
Nia in order to be duty to do this
episode.
But she understands that it's just art.
Jennifer Love Hewitt's she plays the,
uh,
the hand hand job just with the heart of
gold. You know, it's a wonderful show.
She gives people hand jobs at the end of,
of Masu sing them and then
gives advice to their upset.
Um,
yeah.
What would you call the person they're
dating wives and girlfriends come in like,
how could you jerk off my husband?
And then she goes like,
she doesn't love you. He doesn't love you
anymore. That's why he's coming to me.
And then some how they pour their heart
out to her because she's such a good,
she's such a good fucking person that
she can jerk off their boyfriends and
husbands and these people on the
show don't have a problem with it.
And from the second I saw that show,
I was just like, you know what,
I have to be a part of it.
And, um, so this week, Oh yeah,
I'm going to be taping an episode
of, uh, the hand job whisper.
I think Jennifer Love Hewitson and I might
have the wrong fucking show. You know,
it's funny on my cable box, not the
cable box, whatever the fuck you call it,
the to the screen when you
go through the guide, um,
right above the versus network,
you know,
scrolling up trying to find a game and
you go three channels up and then it goes
to the porno channel and a,
you know.
Okay.
It's the weirdest thing ever. You just
see a soccer game, a baseball game,
a basketball game, and then it'll
be like fist fuck part's fun.
And I don't think that was by accident
because if you watch enough sports,
they got the basically for guys,
they got two things.
They don't want to go bald and
they want to fuck something.
And uh, I can remember, I guess
it's true on both those both counts.
Wouldn't you say there?
Huh? Speaking of lonely,
I was just watching television by myself,
speaking to it as if it was
another live human being.
And I saw this commercial for this, this,
this new website called farmers only.
Dot Com.
This is not a commercial people.
This is actually an observation. Um,
it was basically showing, uh, you know,
some,
a couple of ranchers,
a couple of farm girls and they just walk
in the fields by themselves, you know,
playing with their face finger,
playing with each other. You know,
you do that when you were a little kid,
you'd do that little thing where you
put your thumb and index finger together
and both hands.
He didn't kind of do the little,
almost like there's an
invisible tiny screw, you know,
there's some poor woman walking through
like these, uh, a bunch of corn, you know,
and the cows are all concerned to the
point they're actually English to one one
another. You know, about
each of them going,
how the hell are they
going to meet each other?
And then all of a sudden this Waylon
horror comes over the top and just start
singing, yell, never be
lonely. Add Pharma zone,
led.com.
So it's basically their Facebook and
you should go and look at it on Youtube.
That's what you should do. You shouldn't
work, you know, where do you work?
What are you doing?
Is it your dream or somebody else's?
You just a cog in the wheel,
you know,
are they really gonna notice if you
stop working, everybody else is working.
Why don't you just fucking,
you know,
Tour de France just sort of draft behind
a couple people's today. You know,
they could fucking Monday off.
So anyways,
check out this video and you know,
what's the funniest thing about it is
the comments underneath it as the amount
of people who shit on, you know, just
immediately thinking how dumb people are.
It's like these people grow our
fucking food. Do you understand that?
I'm sure they don't know where
the rave is. You know? Well,
who the most popular bands are or how
to get from fucking Brooklyn over to
Staten Island, right? They
don't know how to do that shit.
They don't know how to put on
a fucking shiny shirt, right?
And go jump on the subway and go down
to Wall Street and make sure old people
eat dog food for the rest
of their fucking lives. Yet.
They don't know how to do that, you know,
they know how to do, they had to make,
then I'll make corn, right.
Or planets or it grows.
They don't make it. God makes it, and
he makes that fertile fucking country.
You know, it's gotta be really
hard to catch herpes out there.
You know what I mean? I mean, in
much spread, really fucking slowly.
Jesus Christ. I mean you, you must
fucking rub them at least two loads out.
By the time we get to our house,
just sitting there driving and
driving fucking Tornado, man.
You pull over rob another one
out and by then you'll add it.
You know what the fuck I'm going
over there. Foreign Waste Shit.
I got more teeth in her. That's a deal
breaker. Look, now I'm making fun of him.
I like, or that they're called the flyover
states and no reason to go there. Yeah,
no reason to check it on the food supply.
Uh,
like you're gonna. That'd be good shit
in the fucking, freak him out with,
just show up with like a clipboard.
Fuck.
Are you doing sit at boy or they
actually, you know, something,
they make themselves kind of separatist
cause at the end of, is that even a word?
Um, they actually say this
city folks don't understand.
What don't we understand?
Loneliness. Is that what it is?
Come to New York and be alone
with everybody. You never
heard that. You fucking,
you know what? Fuck them. God
Damn farmers. Jesus Christ. What?
You don't have your cousin's phone
number. Is that what? You're sick of?
Fucking your sisters.
So now you gotta get your own Facebook
and see the jokes that just too easy here.
People,
you know,
sick of fucking a pig.
I want some farm animals.
That'd be great if I just had space.
Yeah.
How many goats would you need to
fucking drink enough? You know,
make your own milk. A couple of
chickens. You got your own eggs, right?
So you've got dead bullshitting.
And I'm Malcolm,
which I know I'm not going to do.
I couldn't do it without laughing.
And then I'd fucking creep out the goat.
Oh Jesus.
I need some people in my life and I
know what the fuck I'm talking about.
And you know, last week I made an
ass of myself as always as always.
And I was talking about the,
uh, the sewage and the drain
and Oh, by the way, you
know something, I'm,
I'm sitting here watching the fucking
La kings and the Phoenix coyotes playing
each other. All right? It's in Phoenix
and they're having a white out.
Everybody's wearing the same t shirt.
But you don't,
you just realize that
the second you do that,
you're just showing the fact that
you have a shitty fucking franchise.
Oh my account this week.
Um,
I hate that this all go whoa.
Where are the same shirt?
It'll be a white out
that'll intimidate them.
They're going to be afraid of the crowd.
I will tell you this, what was amazing,
cause I'm watching this fucking game and
the crowd in Phoenix is Channing bete,
la La beat La,
the iconic chair from the Boston Garden.
It's actually spread all the way
west and jumps sports, you know,
so I had to immediately text Paul Versey
and let them know that because you know,
he's so fucking a namerd with the food
court known as Madison Square Garden
Talk. I was talking to somebody the other
day, we were trying to think of like,
when we think of Madison Square Garden,
what did we think of,
you know,
boxing?
Okay,
Leonard Scanner.
Do you just stick a rock shows?
Nobody thinks about the Knicks or the
fucking rangers other than Nixon Rangers
fans.
It's just another fucking,
that's another one to add to
that list of overrated nicknames.
The world's most famous arena.
You can throw that right in with Lynn.
Sanity Sanchez. Wait, got it.
Bill. You hate New York. All right.
I've made my fucking
point. Um, anyways, so,
which last week this guy tried to tell
me that I should just piss in the shower
because hey, it all goes down. Save
fucking brain anyway. Fuck. Do you care?
What do I care? I don't want it
urine in my toes. I also fucking,
I'm concerned with the fact that
someone else has to use the shower.
How bout that? You know? So, um,
but I was also thinking that they
went down to different drains.
I would think that they would try
and keep that separately separate.
And everybody was like,
everybody writes me, you know,
whenever I say something wrong, everybody
do, you know, it's always like, hey shit.
Right.
So everybody told me that it actually
goes down the same drain and that the
reason why you can't smell the shit
is because they have vents, you know,
which I still no fucking understand,
you know?
Yeah.
Then why don't ice smell shit outside my
house? Where does the, where does the,
the air that was surrounding the Shit,
where does that go?
You know?
And please by all means talk to me like
I'm the biggest fucking moron ever.
Cause I gotta tell you,
I only got like 20 emails about it
and I know how many listeners I have.
So there's a lot of people right now
gone. Really? I didn't realize that. Um,
but still, let me read
this bill. He says, Bill,
about your questioning on
a sewage handling from your
May 7th podcast on whether
toilet water is handled in the
same system as your shower water.
The answer is it depends.
Oh, wait a minute.
I think this guy knows what he's talking
about because he didn't start it off
with, hey shit. Fuck I'm,
he says sewage water that
has no human waste in it. Uh,
this would be considered shower water,
water for dishwater and sinks, et Cetera.
Thank you for explaining where I don't
shit and Piss, um, is called gray water.
What? Uh, what that does contain
human waste is called Blackwater.
All right? Uh, in most
modern urban sewage system,
gray water and black water are treated
and moved within the same system.
Rouse say yet another reason to
live on a farm at Pharma Zone,
it.com
that's going to be embarrassing.
You and your fucking
neighbor are going to join.
You'll be the only ones on the site.
I thought you wanted to fuck me.
I just was too long of a walk.
You know what I'm saying?
Just bless this tornado season. You never
know what's going to happen. Um, and sue,
it's just anyways,
in sewage systems that aren't as
complex or our more remote gray water is
treated in one system,
blackwater is put into another and
usually come composited oh, wait a minute,
let me, okay, so it's not
as complex. Meaning what?
You can't move those all down the same
pipe and somehow separate them again.
You know, sometimes you said stick
with simplicity. I think on this one.
I don't think that motherhood stuff that
goes into my hair and on my body should
ever have touched somebody
else's shit personally.
I don't care how much you treat it.
It's fucking gross.
I got to run for office
and if elected by what? Keep the
gray water away from the blackwater.
Okay.
Bring it back to the old system where
you sit in an outhouse and you never wash
your hair with shit.
Um,
ask not why there's Piss in my hand,
but why this shit and the dre.
Um,
the reason why you do not get sewer
smells in your house is through the use of
an s curve in the toilet
sink and shower drain pipe. If you take
the letter s and turn it on its side,
that's what shaped the drain pipe
makes you, you know, I deserve,
I deserve to be talked to like a child.
Is that what it looks like on its side?
Alright,
take the letter o and turn it on
its side. You still with me? Uh,
when you drain water through this shape,
some water is always left behind
inside the ass. Wonderful.
This forms a seal or blocked through
which sewage gases can't get through.
Oh, that's brilliant. They
should have those on like
subways, you know what I mean?
Just to have it.
Just have it missing in between people.
Okay.
Early sewage systems didn't employ this
shape and it was indeed the case that
sewer gases could enter the
home as far as recycling.
Isn't it amazing how simple that was to
fix though? As far as recycled water,
sewage that is taken from your home
and sent to treatment plans is usually
released back into nature
after it is cleaned.
Mother Nature does the last of the
cleaning process with microbes, et cetera.
Yeah.
Uh, you know what, that's one of
those things that's like a hot dog.
You know what I mean? You just don't
know. You don't want to know what's in it.
That's fucking gross yet.
Brilliant. I find that,
I find I'm finding all of this shit.
What did I just say that
three times it might,
I find I'm finding all of this shit.
You guys think I'm a fucking moron.
You don't what it is.
I have the balls to bring up the
shit that I don't understand. Yeah.
Bill every week and it spans the entire
spectrum of humanity. Go fuck yourselves.
Um,
I actually began disassembling that
carburetor I took apart the primary fuel
ball, took out the floater and all
that. It doesn't have fucking hard.
I knew it wasn't,
I know it wasn't.
And venting and venting,
the carborated,
the carburetor that that is the genius.
Okay.
Take a one apart. I mean that's
not, that's no big fucking deal.
And I imagine once you take it apart,
oh you can put it back together again.
Right. And after a while, I imagine
you can figure out out, fuck it works.
It doesn't seem that complex to make,
um, I'm fucking idiot. No, I'm
doing the whole thing. I got the,
I got the whole chemical right. I bought
myself little. Uh, no I didn't. I'm lying.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna buy this a Turkey
thing that you know to put it in little,
uh,
you know what your roasted Turkey and you
put that on the side with the solution
to clean off all the parts. And I'm
going to build that mother. Fuck.
I should take a before and after picture
with a look and then I'll give you guys
a nice go.
Fuck yourself underneath it for all you
people who trashed me cause I didn't
realize that, you know, it's the same
pipe that the shit and piss goes down.
Why would I know that I'm not a plumber?
You know,
why can't you guys show the
kind of empathy for others
that I do on this podcast
every week?
Um,
would you guys like to learn about an
element? That's my nighttime reading.
I'm really freaking me out.
She,
she can't tell if I'm going crazy or if
I'm starting. I'm trying to build a bomb.
Hold on one sec.
All right.
We hear it. The bill burr podcast,
the Monday morning podcast.
I'm going to try and make you guys either
smarter or bring it down to my level
of stupidity.
So considering I can like,
I know like everybody's name and number
from every football team in the 70s for
the most part.
Wilbert Montgomery 31
Fred Biletnikoff. What the fuck number
was he? That was before my time.
Doug Flutie was 22 Roger Starbuck
was 12 Frank Tarkenton was 10
yeah.
Craig Morton was seventh Dan Pastor
Rainey was seven. Burt Jones was seven.
I'll do all the quarterbacks.
Terry Bradshaw was 12
Brian Sipe the fuck was he was he 17
okay.
All right. All I'm saying is if I can,
if I can fucking memorize that shit,
I can't memorize the periodic chart.
This is yet another thing that [inaudible]
pseudo intelligent thing. You know,
if you can just memorize this shit and
then you go to a cocktail party like we
all do, right? It doesn't everybody on
one of those Roger Moore Tuxedos like me.
And every once in a while
you just go out to a, uh,
you ought to a cocktail party
with other social lights.
Um, you know this, this
is a good thing to know.
If you memorize the periodic chart,
just out of nowhere this,
it's like anytime you say something dumb,
you can just go. Hydrogen is the first,
uh, is element number one
on the periodic chart.
I'm going to memorize this shit and I'm
going to fucking try and understand it.
It's a, and then I can't even say what
I'm going to do with this knowledge.
What'd you guys do if you gradually,
we're listening to me learning all this
shit and then I accidentally blew myself
up my garage.
How compelling would this podcast be?
You'd listen to the first four and
a half years, uh, who's kept no,
the first four and three quarter
years listening to how dumb I was.
And then you just,
you're going to hear that crucial podcasts
where I said that I'm going to buy a
book on this shit. You know, by the way,
has anybody seen the on spike
that fucking thousand ways to die?
Okay.
You guys seen that shorter fucking
creepy ass show that is despite the awful
jokes that they have on top of it,
they just show all these different ways
that people have figured out how to die.
And uh, they just sort of trash
people and say how stupid they are.
And they, um, they fucking just,
these,
they don't try to like tone
down that somebody was dead.
It's weird cause they're
making these really bad jokes.
And by bad I don't mean insensitive. By
bad, I mean not funny over the top of it.
And, but then when they show the person
dead, it's really fucking creepy.
They showed these two girls who
kept filming each other on Youtube,
doing practical jokes, wearing silly
mass and scaring each other. So, uh,
one of the girls brothers, uh,
was a mechanic or something.
So they got that air bag thing and
they stuck it underneath this cushion.
I sound like an old lady right now.
Tell him to death story and
they didn't know it was there,
so she sticks it there.
She tries to get a roommate to sit on
and she's tugging on her roommate pulls
away the girl who put it there,
lands on it,
it shoots are up in the air over the
banister and she fucking breaks her neck
and dies and they go
through the whole thing,
the graphics of her breaking your neck
and then they just show are there with
their head all twisted up.
It's creepy.
A really creepy fucking show.
Um,
and then they have bad jokes over
the top of it. Maybe the bad,
maybe the bad jokes or on purpose.
Why don't I shit on another show and
just burn every fucking bridge I can out
here. Um, hey. You know what?
It's time for a God damn. Uh,
it's time for some advertising. Here we
go. Let's do it. We do it every week.
stamps.com everybody. Um,
if you new to my podcast,
if you're a new to my podcast stamps.com,
do you like going to the Po, uh,
to the podcast, to the post
office? Know maybe you do.
Well, if you do, then
keep going. God bless you.
But if you don't and you
were thinking like, you know,
I wish there was a way it can handle all
this business within my own apartment,
within my own house,
within my own cardboard box,
as a homeless person that I live in.
But for some reason to have some
sort of Internet connection, I'm,
all you need to do is go to
stamps.com. Okay. I use stamps.com.
It's great. I sent out all my DVDs.
This way they give you a scale,
you can weigh out your stuff and you can
use your computer and you can print out
a legal stamps, bing, Bang, boom.
Plus after you do it a couple times,
you've got it down, you've got it down
and you can fly through it. All right,
so you go to stamps.com a
special offer for my listeners.
Use My last name bur bur for a no risk
trial plus $1,010 bonus offer includes
the digital scale and $55 of free postage.
All right,
go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the radio microphone
at the top of the homepage.
Type in Burger Bu Rr that stamps.com
and enter [inaudible]. There you go.
All right. Where the hell am I?
Back to the damn. You know what?
I finally figured out
how to use this computer.
I didn't realize when
I bought this computer,
I then had to download everything else.
I thought with the amount
of money that I spent on it,
they would've given me some sort of
program that I could have written it,
but I can't. I gotta go download that.
You know, there's another 20 bucks.
Let's siphon that out
of his fucking wallet.
You know,
I, I'm going to say I even
say it, I'm just going
to see, you know, come see my act. I have
a nice day. Have a nice all new chunk.
Come see my act. Don't see me. Just come
by and go see my act. A car repair bill.
You're right.
Fixing your car is a good feeling.
I had trouble with the passenger
side window for months.
If finally went out on me a couple of
Fridays ago and it was stuck all the way
down in the door with the forecast
showing three days of rain. Anyway,
I ordered the part, took my door
apart. Tools everywhere, dirty hands,
had some music going,
feeling like a man baby.
I had just found out a couple hours
before my wife and I are having a boy.
Congratulations though.
That's awesome. Uh, he goes,
I didn't really know what I was doing,
but I did a youtube search
replacing Nissan power window motor.
Boom. It was there and it, and
it took me through it. Yeah.
That's all I've been doing.
That's how I fixed my blender.
Youtube is the shit.
The fucking Internet is to shit.
People spend so much time writing
racial stuff and jerking off to porn.
You could just, you could go on youtube
and you could teach yourself anything.
You can learn how to play guitar.
You can learn to play drums,
you can learn how to fix a fucking
carburetor. Anything you want to do. Um,
all I can tell you is stay
away from expert village. I'm,
their videos are short.
They're not informative,
they suck and they are like this fucking
plague because once you get into their
expert village, ah, fucking
vortex, you can't get out of it.
You've got to like literally shut your
whole fucking computer down and start
over again. Um, okay.
I don't know. I'm 100% for that. I fucked
up the Mirror on the side of my car and
mmm.
MMM.
I just have to have enough time in my
schedule to just pop that thing off.
I've watched a guy do it. It's
simple. There's two screws,
then you pop the thing off.
Then there's two more.
The unplugged the fucking thing.
Pull it out.
You stick the next one plugged
the thing that Jesus was,
I can't even fucking explain it.
Whatever. I don't fucking, oh,
hang on a second.
Sorry.
I had to adjust my fucking white there.
Um, yeah, I've actually a citizen,
he has been out of town. She doesn't
even know I've gone out and I've,
I've fucking blown like, I think
300 bucks on tools, you know,
all over the map. Some shit for cars, some
shit for fixing stuff around the house.
And um, you know, it's funny,
she just looks at me and smiles at me
like she thinks it's cute and it's really
fucking annoying me.
It's just motivating me to
want to fix something. Like,
you know, I fixed the fucking blender and
I didn't get any credit. She just like,
yeah, you know? Yeah, it's cool.
Well, I, I said what I said, I said,
I said I was happy for you. I was, you
know, like, no, it doesn't remember.
It's like you,
you wanted to throw the fucking thing
out there was to cost me a couple hundred
bucks to fix it for seven bucks.
Right. Anything, you know,
you know what it's like to go on stage
and have a great set and then you come
home and your bomb in your own house.
That's my life people.
That is my fucking life. Um, somebody
sent me a douchey thing on Twitter,
giving me shit about something
that I said, you know, and I,
I really got to learn to stop taking the
bait. I didn't write the person back.
I don't even know if I can even
fucking talk about this. They would,
they were calling me out on something,
which technically they were right.
Hey, you said this year, act and now
you're a promoting that. You know,
it's a typical fucking
thing where it's like,
this person isn't offended
by anything I fucking say,
but then all of a sudden it comes
around them. They're fucking world.
And now they're offended and sitting
there giving me shit saying I'm a piece of
shit when I know God damn well you're on
fucking youtube watching all my fucking
videos for free watching all these
other comedians videos for free,
putting other people out of work.
So go fuck yourself. All right.
See that that was all in code.
That's for the person who wrote me.
Go Fuck Yourself. You fucking
cunt. Why don't you pay for music?
Why don't you pay for something?
All right? You'd like uni.
You're not putting people out of work.
Go fuck yourself podcasts for free.
It's still for free.
Okay,
so why don't you go skip down the street
and fucking tweet to somebody who gives
a fuck. There we go. Whew. Got
that out of my fucking system.
Do you know, understand? You know
what's the worst thing about me?
Aside from my general
contempt for humanity,
is I have a complete fucking inability
to not insult and curse people
when I feel that I've been wronged.
You know? So then I've, I've said
this in my act, even when I'm right,
I become wrong.
You know,
buddy of mine piss me off and
fucking talk to him for three weeks.
Finally calls me up. He's like, hey bro,
have talked to you. Was everything cool?
He knows everything's not cool. He knows
he was a cunt all right now. And I said,
no, everything's cool though. I've just
been busy, but by blah blah, blah, blah.
Right.
Because I don't have the
fucking ability at this point.
I don't have the ability to, to,
to be like, you know, listen,
I just want to say that the other day
I felt that there was a few things that
were said they had, I, I,
I didn't appreciate and um,
I'm not sure if you meant him in that
way, but I just, I just can't do that.
Jim called me a couple of weeks.
Yes.
Cause you're a cunt because of the fucking
shit you said the other day and you
know what you were doing it don't
even fucking go fuck yourself.
That's how it goes down,
you know? Ah, yeah. Oh.
Gives a shit.
You know?
You know where I really fucking
can't stand is that fucking guy.
He does those Ford commercials,
that creepy fucking guy
with that. You know what?
You know what makes him so creepy? Fucking
pleasant. He's got this pleasant tone.
I think he used to do the dirty jobs
thing. I don't know if he still does it.
He wears that fucking
hat with no logo on it.
So you can't describe what he
really looked like. You know,
after he gets done feeling
up your fucking daughter,
he's always hanging out with
people younger than him. You know,
he's a guy walking down the street and
uh, yeah they make, my girlfriend says it,
look, it makes my butt look better. And
then this fucking girl is like, Hey,
nice ass. And he's like, that's not
my girlfriend. That fucking guy.
I don't trust people like that.
That guy with his pleasant,
that whole pleasant,
just even Keel,
just sitting there with
his hands in his pockets.
Just fucking 100% flat line
nonthreatening. That guy,
I swear to God will pour nuclear waste
into the water supply for a corner office.
I'm not saying him literally,
but that just people like whatever,
whatever that fucking images. I don't
trust pleasant people. Is that my,
is that my issue? I
ain't know, I just don't,
I don't trust people like
all this Tibetan monks,
you know was the last time you saw in
them losing their shit cause they got a
parking ticket standing there and they're
orange robe yelling at some overweight
woman before she gets back on her
fucking goddamn moped. You know,
I don't trust them. You don't what it
is. I like people to pray in public.
I don't like, they sit around a lot or
you know, or are doing that shit right.
It's funny. I bet they fucking steel
flat screens, all those Tibetan monks.
It's why the way those long,
it's where they were drapes.
Just stealing all this swag out of
your fucking house is one of them.
Sits there just calmly smiling at you.
You don't swell. They all dress the same.
Just like the drug dealers on the wire,
those Tibetan monks at the same
fucking thing. You can't describe them.
They all just start running.
It's like a school of fish.
You can't figure out what the
fuck's going on. You know,
cause I fuck that ended up
trash and monks, oh whatever.
If this is all just self hatred.
I got it. W when is this anchor?
We're going to go away. I'm a, I'm
already past the halfway point.
I've already played at least
10 holes in my life. I had to,
if I'm going to be 44 years old,
times two is 88
88 Eric Lindros. Hey, wait a minute.
Let's see what element that is.
Let's see.
What all 88 is you guys interested?
Is there an (888) 018-0980 eight radium,
radium. Evidently it's a, it's
what makes your watches glow.
Radium was the titanium of the early
19 hundreds it was the brilliant,
shiny,
powerful element everyone
wanted to associate their
products with and sell it to
whites only. They never
have that part in, you know,
they always keep that
racist part like separate.
Do you have any of you guys ever noticed
that shit and like whenever they talk
about the good old days about
baseball, you know, boy, Oh boy,
go see Mickey Mann all yet that Bennett
in an order that take me out to the ball
game. Well, whenever they show
the Jackie Robinson storage,
just the Jackie Robinson story and
it's just about race, they never do.
They never tell both those stories
at the same time. Boy, Oh boy,
when I saw Duke Snider by meets up peanuts
and cracker jacks and they keep all
of that ugliness out away from the game,
then they tell the racist part separately.
You know,
when these fucking people with the
Goddamn periodical book it, there's,
there's no difference.
Um,
radium was the titanium of
the early 19 hundreds. Uh,
the Klan used to shoe
their horses with it.
I'm just going to fill in the shift
of these. They leave out of it. Uh,
just as many titanium products
today contained no actual titanium.
Um, many radium products of a
century goes such as radium,
furniture, Polish and radium.
Toothpaste contained no radium.
Interesting. I wonder if the knobs
of, of Jp Morgan, that piece of shits,
fucking walking sticks had
any radium and them, you know,
as he pushed Woodrow Wilson into office.
Why isn't that in here? You know,
fuck this book. I am going to
memorize it though. All right.
You know what,
like I said,
I'm doing the hand job whisper this week
and the next week I'm going to be at
fly out in Burbank,
California, the 25th and 26th.
Okay.
And if for some reason you ever wanted
to see Ralph malf put together an hour of
comedy, but he never did stand
up. I am a wonderful substitute.
I will be out there.
I'm going to be at the mall
people on May 25th and 26th,
uh,
doing my jokes or some semblance of them.
I'm actually having a really good time
putting together this hour because, uh,
I don't know. I don't know where
it's going to come from because
usually I just talk about my life.
And as you can tell,
talking about fixing carburetors
is not exactly a mainstream topic.
You know,
can't put together an extra five minutes
for late night television talking about
carburetors. Can I, how the fuck do
you make that mainstream? Oh, Jesus,
what the hell am I talking about here?
Let's get to some more advertising here.
Oh, we have a new advertiser this
week. Everybody, um, the man great.
The white. Yeah, the man. Great.
What a fuck is the copy get worse?
Where is it?
Oh, here it is. Here it is. It's supposed
to view and download it. All right.
Jesus Christ. Uh, the man. Great. Uh,
okay.
Father's Day's coming up.
Everybody father's day is coming up.
We today was mother's incident yesterday,
I should say.
Yesterday was mother's Day.
You know, you bought a flowers.
Now who's coming year? Dad.
Ladies before. Gentlemen.
Now it should dad's day coming up,
right?
And nobody gets slighted like
your dad. Okay. Your mom,
she always gets nice stuff,
you know, unless her kids
are complete pieces of crap,
right? But dads, they always get screwed.
They get a razor. They get some sort of,
you know, sergeant wrench or some,
some bs. Right? Well, they got it.
They got a great thing for you this year.
All right.
Does your father have a grill?
No.
Then what is he doing in this country?
You don't have a grill.
I think you should be convicted
of the, of being like a spy. Um,
of course your dad has a
grill. He's a man, right? He
brought you into this world.
Um, this is the deal for father's
Day. There's only one perfect gift.
It's the man Greg Grill
enhancement system. What's a man?
Great us man grades are
100% made in America.
Baby cast iron grilling greats.
These heavy duty grilling grades deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
steakhouse flavor you've been looking
for. Um, basically what it is is,
is you know,
if you have a grill,
which you probably have is some
sort of stainless steel, uh,
basically cheapo grilling grapes
and these are the real deal.
You know, it's like you went
out, you bought a Ford focus in.
What they're doing is they're dropping a,
a big block Chevy right in that account.
I can on what I'm saying. Um, anyways,
these heavy duty grilling greats
deliver exactly what you need.
A with man greats patented design chicken,
steak or veggies will never taste so good.
No more flare ups,
no more dry dry meat. A guaranteed, uh,
take advantage of our $20 Monday morning
podcast special today by clicking on
the man great banner on the
podcastPage@billbird.com as a bonus,
every bill bird.com order comes with a
heavy duty man. Great grilling brush.
She can actually clean the thing too.
Um,
they're made in America a
hundred percent cast iron.
They're going gonna make your steaks,
tastes like steak house quality.
If you already have a grill, you just
take those aluminum or whatever they are,
stainless steel pieces of junk
off you drop these one's right on.
You get a fee or dead,
you get it for yourself and you make
yourself some great burgers just in time
for the summer. Just in
time for this summer. Um,
all right, there you go. So
there's that part. You don't,
if I actually was doing this live,
I would take a collar at this point.
You know, we're talking to
Mike, Mike out in Ohio. Mike,
what's going on? You know, I just want
to say I'm a big fan of the show and uh,
you know,
go fuck yourself.
I never liked taken college back in
the day when I used to do uninformed,
there we go. Car Report. All right.
Advertising requests. Hey Bill,
you've been asking your listeners, Whoa,
what the fuck just happened? Facetime.
All of a sudden I'm looking
myself doing this podcast.
It's computer freaks me out.
Advertising quest. Bill,
you've been asking your listeners for
advertisement and discounts. Suggestion.
How about a Snapple?
Kiwi?
Strawberry Snapple is my
all time favorite drink.
It's this serious.
You want me to advertise Snapple
cause you like Kiwi. Strawberry.
How much are they? You need a break
on that. It's my all time favorite.
If I could find a way to get your
listeners a discount on that,
you would be even more awesome than
you already are. Please, please,
please look into this
kiwi strawberry Snapple.
MMM.
You know what, Dude, I'm
going to go out on a limb.
I don't think that's ever going to happen.
You know I don't drink Snapple.
I don't even know what it is.
What is it?
Is it supposed to be like juice?
Yeah,
I don't buy any of that shit. You go to
a real, you go to a real juice. How snow?
Yeah. One of those places where
fucking hippies hanging around.
You want real juice?
She got to go to hippies or go to farmers,
you know,
other than that, I mean, isn't
it like made out of like corn
and black matter and gray matter Assam?
Shit.
It's all like fucking sugar,
isn't it? Snapple? I have no idea
dude. I'm not advertising
Kiwi. Strawberry Snapple.
Yeah. That's something
that I would, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't even have drank that and the
seventh grade to some about Kiwi just
doesn't sound good. Strawberry,
Snapple, maybe blueberry.
I'd be a Debbie Downer with that.
Kiwi strawberry. I don't know.
Isn't that like the, the uh,
what is that big cartoon movie?
Everybody's going to see that it
has like every superhero in it.
Is that any good by the way? Because
I'm going on the road again. I might,
I might want to go see a couple
of movies cause anybody, uh,
can anybody suggest one?
Uh,
the fuck is the name of that.
I'm going out of my fucking mind.
You know what it is this week, people,
I got so much shit on my fucking mind.
I gotta leave the Goddamn House again.
I got to make sure it's all fucking,
let's play a game called what bill
should had done with his life.
I should have been a teacher.
You don't just tapped out.
Just
done that. Right? You weren't
from fucking September to June.
You get two months off.
You get a week off in February.
April vacation.
Christmas vacation.
Yeah, out the door. Three. Right.
Only only to do is just have a bunch of
pens in your front pocket and everybody
thinks you're working.
Once you teach it,
the first year you got it down and
he'd just keep coming in there. Right.
Nine to three, no extra help, but
I don't get it now. You'll get it.
You'll get just keep coming to
class. You'll get there. You'll,
you'll figure it out by November,
you know,
start banging the fucking hot
math teacher or some shit.
I just want to share it that she
had some fucking little shit car,
little one bedroom apartment, just
fucking grown food out on the balcony.
Be that guy,
you know,
like I would dies and people
don't know for like three weeks.
Okay.
Did you hear about them by
the time they found him?
His parakeet eight half his face.
MMM.
That'd be a sad existence when it,
okay.
Well wouldn't it? I don't know
what to tell you. You know what I,
every time I do this podcast,
I sit over here and I look at
my guitar and my Wah Wah pedal.
I'm trying to get the balls to
fucking play something for you guys.
But the thing is is I need to
get warmed up just to suck.
Forget about just being straight up awful.
Um,
but I'm telling you I'm growing
by leaps and bounds in that thing.
There's somebody having a Wah Wah pedal
that's like a makes you actually sound
like, you know what the
fuck you doing. You know,
I was going to watch one of those uh,
Hall of fame rock and Roll Hall of fame
thing cause they had like guns and roses
and a couple of the bands that I liked
in it and it was like fucking three hours
long. And at that point it's just
like, dude, go fuck yourself.
You know,
I don't want to watch it for fucking
nine hours actually put it on.
And I think it was that Guy
Donovan who sang that song. Yeah.
Blow the way Dan below the ocean there.
Well to be z Libby when fucking uh,
Joe Peci fucking killed Billy
batts that song that they play.
So they liked the inducted this guide
Donovan and he was talking about this
poetic bullshit, but I couldn't
understand what the fuck you, we,
I just turned it on.
I hope he doesn't have something wrong
with them mentally cause then I'll look
like a Douche.
I thought it was Brian May um,
have any of my thoughts over the last
20 minutes even been like even remotely
connected. Um, all right,
advice. You know what it is,
is I also have the stress
if I have to learn my lines,
so the hand job whisperer and uh,
I got to get on that shit too. Um,
all right, advice. Conscious
three of her best friend.
Hey Bill, big fan of yours from Canada
and listened to the podcast every week.
That's awesome. All right. I bought with
my girlfriend for over four years now.
Dumper, uh, we own a house together,
Jesus and have the usual
relationship ups and downs.
I'd like your advice and how
she talks about me to this lady.
She calls her best friend.
The friend talks relentless shit about
how terrible I am and how would she be so
much happier with one of her guy friends.
What
I just got lost.
The friend talks relentless shit.
What your girlfriend about how terrible
you are and how she'd be much happier
with one of her guy friends.
Oh,
she's trying to fix her up
with one of her friends.
Even going so far as to invite them both
to the same party, knowing full well,
I won't be there. I've approached
my lady about it and she says,
I'm being paranoid. I've seen messages
exchanged between the two ladies,
so I know I'm not crazy.
My question is how do I tell her that
are best that our friend is a miserable,
lonely cunt and to get her to
stay out of our relationship,
love the podcast, keep up the great
work and go fuck yourself. Um,
dude, I dunno about that whole
thing. Like why do you want it?
Why do you want to at this point
get this girl out of your,
like the, the, the,
the other girl trying to like hook
your girl up with guys you know,
to meet instead of use is your
secondary problem at this point.
Your first problem is that you
saw evidence of that and the,
the woman you're with lied and said it
isn't happening and tried to say that
you're being paranoid.
MMM.
I Dunno. I, I don't, I don't,
I don't know what to tell Ya.
If I was in that
situation and I saw those,
I, I would've, I don't know. I would've
taken the phone and be like, well yeah,
what the fuck is this? Once again, of
course cursing, stop yelling at me. Stop
acting like you're not, you're
being a fucking cunt. All right.
Do you not want to be in this? Let's
sell this fucking house. We'll end it.
I don't understand why every time we
try and talk about south fuck you.
That's how I'd handle it. Right? Why is
she doing that Shit behind your back?
Do you? This is what she's doing, dude.
I think she might be out there
trying to fucking, you know,
treat it like monkey bars.
What she's going to swing right out
of your relationship into another one.
Why else would she be doing that?
You've seen the messages
exchanged between the two ladies,
so you know you're not quite, did you
say that to her? I'm not being paranoid.
I read your phone, right? And
then you come off like you're a,
that's a weird thing when you start doing
some Jed Ger Hoover Shit on the person
you're with and you feel like a piece
of Shit snooper then when you actually
find the evidence, there's no way
to bring up the evidence without,
without them being like,
why is snooping,
okay.
You know, women can be
like, I just had a feeling.
Yeah,
maybe guys can say that too.
I had a feeling I had a feeling
that something weird was going on.
You were acting weird and my gut told
me to check your phone. And I did.
And I found exactly what I was failing.
All right.
Why are you mad at me for snooping?
I was right. You know what?
I'd have to get a fucking search warrant.
This isn't a show. Go Fuck Yourself.
I was right. See, that's what I do.
And then it's, it's just, you know,
becomes about me cursing. Um, all right,
well let's say for whatever reason
you want to stay with this girl.
So your question is, how do I tell
her that a friend is a miserable,
lonely cunt and to get her to
stay out of the relationship?
MMM,
that's a tough one because
it's her friend. You know what?
You have to do
everything l all the way that
I talk don't talk that way.
But you got to do is you have to go
out and you have to buy a sweater.
Just ride with me on this one.
All right.
You got to buy a sweater and maybe like
some penny loafers and some dockers.
You put the whole thing together,
part your hair on this side,
like Mr. Rogers and then you just sit
down at the kitchen table with your hands
folded in front of you.
Like somebody trying to be the teacher's
pet and you just wait for her to come
home.
Okay.
It's going to totally catch her off guard,
but you're going to be dressed so
I'm pleasantly like that. Duchenne,
all those commercials that she's
not going to feel threatened.
She's just going to be a little creeped
out and just be like, how do you, what?
What? Why you sitting here by yourself
dress like Mr. Rogers. Just be like, ah,
I just did something we need to talk
about. And you just sit her down, ed.
You just tell her that,
you know.
See, I don't know how to do it
without getting mad and cursing.
MMM.
I just don't understand why you're
hanging out with this person.
She keeps trying to get it in
the middle of our relationship.
I don't have any friends who are doing
that and I feel like you're choosing your
friendship.
I feel like your friendship with her was
more important than your relationship
with me.
Okay.
All right, and if that's the case, then
we need to sell the house at night.
I'll say that next. I don't know
what the fuck to tell you, dude.
I don't want to tell you dude,
because I wouldn't do this.
I mean you, you said, how do I tell her?
Tell her that a friend is a miserable,
lonely cutting to get stay out of the
relationship. That's what I would say.
You know?
Listen, your friend is a
miserable, lonely, can't all right.
I'm sick of her button
into our relationship.
Then every night she'd go out and be
like, oh, you're hanging out with them.
Miserable lonely content.
I want to say,
can you hang out with that and miserable
chick? Tell her I said, what's up?
How many bad things is she going to
say about me tonight? I don't know,
Dude. I Dunno. That's fucked.
That whole thing is fucked up.
I don't know if you can't do that.
You know what I would do if I was you,
I'd start finding some good
looking women to hang out with.
You know,
just in case she's getting
ready to jump ship,
you'll have something nice to
land on too, right? I Dunno.
Do Women even listened to this podcast
anymore? I can't remember the last time.
One road in. I'm just such an off putting
Douche. I'm overrated. A overrated,
underrated for this week. A overrated, uh,
getting into a four car pile up in
Boston while listening to the podcast.
Uh, see at Hampton beach. Get outta
here. You got into a four car pile up.
He said, go fuck yourself. You
don't, you didn't even save.
It was over eight overrated.
It is overrated.
Well, I said the listen to it in your
cubicle. I'm sorry dude. What happened?
What happened to your car?
Four car pile up.
You're going to blame my podcast for that
shit. Anyways, that's a podcast
for this week. Everybody, uh,
notice it a, I got a couple of
things I've got to talk about.
I got a couple more advertising things
and I got to tell you where I'm going to
be.
What do you want to hear first?
You want to get the homework
out of the way first.
You want to hear where I'm going to be?
Huh? Well, you hold, you hold the power.
You have the fast forward buttons.
You can do whatever you want here. Um,
where is, where is it? Where
is busy schedule? PIPPA man,
great advertising are right.
Uh,
gamefly we still got
gamefly hang in strong game,
fly.com everybody.
I'm sorry.
Game fly.com/burr. All right, you
get a 15 day free trial, free trial.
Um, typically it's only 10 days,
but you get an extra five days.
If you go through the link on the podcast
page, there's no late fees. New titles,
Netflix for video games.
Uh,
www.game fly.com/pir for a
15 day free special trial.
Free Trial,
8,000 video games delivered right to your
house or to your apartment or write to
your PC. Can you beat that? I
don't think you can. All right. So,
oh, Billy fat again, Louie fat again.
It's got to take us some fucking weight
and I'm going to be starting in June
when I go on my whirlwind tour
of this lovely country. Um,
and I'm hitting a lot of cities
that I, I, I don't think either.
I haven't been to in a while
or I've never been to, uh,
in the history of me running
my yap in history. This is the,
I got San Jose coming
up June 15th and 16th.
Then I'm at the Chicago theater
June 17th with Vince Vaughn.
Steve burned and uh, I don't know who else
is on it. It's going to be a huge show.
Then June 29th,
30th and July 1st I'm in
at the Ontario Improv,
inland empire, Ontario, California. Um,
and I fucking hate that Gig. Am I ain't
gonna lie to you. It's not the Gig.
I hate that fucking drive it.
Drive is the worst.
I don't give a shit what
time you drive out there.
It's nine hours of fucking
traffic. No traffic. You know,
I could get out there in 45
minutes with traffic. You know,
it's going to be like three hours at a,
I'm actually getting a hotel sitting
in a hotel for 45 minute drive from my
house. Um, but whatever shows
are going to be great. Uh,
July 14th to be at the
Hampton Beach Casino Ballroom,
Newport Yachting Center. July
15th, Carolines on Broadway.
26th to the 29th of July. They
come the weird ones. Orlando,
Florida, Orlando, Florida. September 7th,
eighth,
and ninth.
I'm going to be at the Bray Improv on
the 21st 22nd and 23rd of September.
And I also know I have a date in a,
in North Carolina.
Let me see if I can find that
date for you. Hang on a second.
All right, Darrin is, I'm going to be
at the uh, the comedy zone in Charlotte,
North Carolina. September
13th, 14th and 15th,
um, hanging around for that
panthers game on Sunday.
And then also I am going to be at
the comedy zone in Jacksonville,
Florida on September 27th,
28th and 29th hanging out to see
the jaguars playing the bangles.
I'm not going to all the football
teams. I haven't seen, um,
this year while whilst building my new
hour and right about then my new hour
will become announced. They go, I've
got a couple of a down home once,
Orlando, Jacksonville and uh, Charlotte,
North Carolina nine Oh people Orlando
with you think you hit because Shaq lives
there as does tiger woods,
you know, I dunno. I,
you know what,
I don't know what I think about.
I don't know anything about Orlando,
Florida. What do you guys do there?
You got that,
the fucking old ass a Disney world.
Is that what it is?
The Epcot Center there was actually
built when Rubik's cube was still
fascinating. Is that still
good down there? Disneyworld?
I haven't been there since. I was
like, well last time I was there, um,
last time I was there,
the fucking Epcot center look like the
death star in one of those when they were
just building it and one of those star
wars movies that those nerds like to
watch.
You know,
I really can tell you guys how
much I fucking hate star wars.
Hate Star was so much that I only like
empire strikes back because he almost
kills Han Solo and he chops
his hand off. Right. Um,
no, wait, that was Luke Skywalker, right?
All the nerds just freaked out. How
could you confuse them? Um, yeah,
it just wasn't into it. And I also
thought Chewbacca was fucking useless.
Meet Shabaka was basically big foot.
They just gave it a different name.
Typical Hollywood movie, you know,
steal an idea, give it a different name,
and then stand there being like,
what, what? I don't owe you any money.
You know that Chewbacca like fought the
$6 billion man like six years earlier on
television. Booty. People
saw him with his bionic eye.
Right.
And they find each other and then a few
years later he's at ease and space. No,
wait, that would, the big foot
was Andre the giant. Yeah.
And all they did was fill in his
face and then he had Chewbacca.
I just didn't fucking get,
I don't understand Chewbacca,
the fucking,
uh,
it's like an orangutan or something
rang a Tan, I would say. Rang a Tang,
like the drink rang a Tan. That's what it
was. Right. Why are you shooting a gun?
Did Hand Solo go run up to Darth Vader
and try to bite his neck like a fucking
tiger? I didn't get it. I didn't
like, I didn't like Chewbacca.
I didn't like how he sat up.
Right. You know what I mean?
I didn't like that whole,
I didn't,
I just didn't like it and
I hated the fucking robots,
you know?
I thought c three Po was just a rip
off of that dude from lost in space.
The Gay guy running around.
Um,
how the fuck did that guy ever
end up on a space trip? I mean,
he just didn't have the, he just didn't
have the, she didn't have the, the, uh,
I dunno,
what's the word I'm looking for?
He just didn't have the
chemical makeup to do with like,
the guy was like absolutely
scared of his own fucking shadow.
Why in God's name would he get on a space
ship and travel through space when he
has stayed home, you know? Well, Shit,
Bill, you don't understand how planes fly.
Get you get you get on every
fucking week, don't you? Um,
the hell was I talking about?
Let's try to work our way back here.
$6 million man fucking bigfoot Sasquatch.
Oh,
Epcot sell the fucking Disneyland.
I mean,
it's got to look like the God damn
projects at this point, doesn't it?
Did they keep it up? Did
they work on it? Um, I mean,
what can they really
offer you at this point?
Did they make the rides bigger for all
the fatties people weren't nearly as fat
the last time I went there
when I went down there,
the big thing to do is when you went to
Florida was you got one of those Mesh
shirts that had the number
on it and it said Florida 78,
79 or [inaudible] 80. That
was like a big deal. And um,
he pulled you tube socks up to your knees.
You had little Larry Bird shorts on and
you will probably wearing Adidas dragons
or a either Nike Cortez or the, the, the,
the nylon ones.
The blue ones with the yellow stripe
or swoosh. I think that was about it. And
then the broke kids weren't Tom mccants,
you know, and socks said the of the
elastic thing was fucked up, up top.
And that was it. That's the last
time I went. Oh No, wait. I,
I went there about a year ago, two
years ago. I don't fucking know.
Florida's a weird state,
you know, they got all that,
all that money down there in Miami.
And other than that,
you got a bunch of people live in with
mosquitoes trying to act like they got
money. You know, even the
mansions down there in Florida,
they all look like the fucking
cheesecake factory, don't they?
He likes some like Americanized
version of like a Mexican restaurant.
And they have like those manmade,
like fake lagoons.
They put people out there
and like every other day,
like somebody gets murdered
or a hurricane hits the house.
It's just a horrible fucking state. And
I'm going to be performing there on, uh,
September.
Oh Shit.
You know what I got into,
I got into the fucking NBA playoffs.
I finally got into it and um,
I'm loving it.
I'll back into basketball. I got no
choice to Bruins were knocked out,
but I got to tell you, I fucking hate
to, I hate the officiating. Okay.
The officiating is the fucking worst.
She can't even like bump into anybody.
You can't go near anybody if there's
any sort of touching of human beings,
those fucking jerk offs blow
the whistle and they just stick,
kill the drama. Just let them play the
fucking game. You know, it's the worst.
Yesterday was I was watching the
Lakers playing Denver and uh,
Pau Gasol, the worst thing that
ever happened was Paul was,
Saul got called out for being soft. They
called them the tin man after the will,
they lost to the Celtics in the finals.
So now he's like trying
to be this hard ass guy.
So anytime, like he'll, like he's trying
to tip the ball, he tips it up again,
tips it up again. Then it finally goes
in. Then he tries to do the Kevin Garnett,
you know, primal scream.
He's like, ah, right.
And he tries to act like
he's just fucking bad ass,
but anytime he gets called for a foul,
you see the real him.
He'll tip it in, it'll dunk,
go do all this stuff and
standing there going around,
punching this chest, and then like
the second they call a file on me,
he's just like,
just say what his fucking mouth hanging
open and just shaking his head head.
You know, he just seems like you'd have
a really like soft handshake, you know?
It's probably good at playing the
piano. I'm just not buying it. Um,
what do you guys stick to next round?
We'll at me talking basketball.
I don't know shit about it.
I still only know four Celtics.
I know the big four. That's it. I
don't know anybody else I ever watched.
I haven't watched one fucking game this
year. Um, I went to one basketball game,
went to the Lakers, Oklahoma
game. When Metta world peace, um,
throw an elbow and I love how
everybody judged him about deck.
Oh well he's name is metta world peace,
but he fucking elbow Sabine the head.
Dad's dot. Two peaceful as it,
right. Well, what about God?
You know he's supposed to
be, you know, the, the,
the king of peace and all I hear is how
he's mad at me and his son's going to
come down here and murder a bunch of
people throwing lightening bolts on the
back of some fucking seven edit horse.
You know,
what would you do if, if Metta world
peace was the second coming of Christ?
Wouldn't that be fucking awesome?
I would love to go to some area and
meeting after that if they just proved it
without a fucking doubt that
that was the son of God.
Yeah.
Do you know how much I pray for shit
like that or like for the toughest guy in
the NFL did just come out of the closet
and say he's gay and then continuing to
kick the shit out of people. Those are
the kinds of things that I want to see,
you know, at this point. I mean, what
the fuck else you gotta do it right?
They got cars that are going to start
parking themselves. Do you see that?
The ditsy broad they had in the car,
that Ford focus commercial with that dose,
with the hat, with no
label on it, you know, um,
she's just saying like, oh my God,
that car's like parking itself.
What was that movie with that
stupid little robot? The cartoon
and it had people in the future and there
was so fat that they couldn't fucking
move.
They just sort of sloshed around,
didn't they like remote
control wheel barrels?
You remember that there was a little
robot that looked like a blender and of
course it had some sort of relationship
with like a fucking, I dunno,
nail gun. I don't, I
don't remember movies.
There's gotta be a love
story that's gotta be hard.
I don't know what the fucking movie was.
You know what it was?
It was called iPod Wally.
Wasn't there some Wally in there?
Yeah,
I dunno.
Whatever.
But they said everyone was gonna be so
fat and the fucking future that they,
that we stopped,
we didn't have legs anymore and all these
people got fucking offended and here
they are. They're making all this shit.
You don't even have to think anymore.
Does that even make sense? Do
you do have to thank, don't Ya.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
this is one of these podcasts I should
have ended 10 minutes ago because every,
you know what I sound right now,
I sound like somebody who says they
didn't commit the murder and I'd keep
hanging around talking just
further con convicting myself.
I keep saying I'm not dumb
and I just keep doing things just to say
otherwise. Um, all right. Here's the deal.
I'm doing the, uh, the hand job whisper
this week and then I'm, I'm performing it.
Flappers that's my, may I
get jealous, um, in June.
Then I'm doing some other stuff and just
come on out and see me and a w eight.
Let me send me some,
uh,
some movies that I should go see that
I'll then and spliced together with other
movies. You guys can laugh at me. Uh,
that's it. Uh, hey, keep going to,
why amazon.com through my website.
Go to [inaudible] dot com click on the
podcast page and click on the banner for
Amazon. If you want to go buy
something, if you do buy something,
they'll kick me back a percentage.
It doesn't cost you any more money.
In 10% of that goes to the
wounded warrior project.
If amazon.com ever gives me any money.
Okay.
Oh, that's how businesses, um, anyways,
that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. Um, my predictions,
um, I want to say the kings are
going to beat Phoenix this point.
That games should be over. I want to say
it, but there's just something about a,
okay.
You know, I don't want to jinx him.
Ellie's never won a Stanley Cup, right?
Neither is Phoenix,
but they haven't been waiting that long.
So I got a roof la and then you got the,
uh,
New York rangers versus the, uh,
the country, New Jersey, Denver,
Denver,
New Jersey devils and um,
I dunno, I think the devils are going
to win just because they just play,
play that fucking goddamn defense
and you can't get around it.
Then he got a dumping in and chasing.
I'll up fucking bullshit. Who knows?
That's the podcast for this week. Go fuck
yourselves. I will see you next week.
God bless, Eh, uh, that's
it. All right. See Ya.